[Music]
I have a slightly different career in
the sciences in that I am a
professionally trained scientist I have
a doctorate in astrophysics and I've
done my own Astrophysical research but I
decided to emphasize science
communication and actually you'll go
more into education and policy and and
trying to communicate science to the
public and the interesting thing to me
is that that means that there are a lot
of people that don't know me very well
that have seen me on television that
assume that I'm a brilliant scientist
yeah the reason this person is on
television is she must be the best
astronomer you know of the day and
that's certainly not true at all and
then I have a lot of professional
colleagues you know who are not
necessarily cruel but you know they
really view me as a bit of a failure I
didn't become a publishing scientific
professor a research professor which is
what I was really trained to be and
especially in these days of social media
a television show will come out and all
of a sudden I get messages from
strangers who say that they love me and
strangers that say that they hate me and
I often get questions from from young
students and they say well how did you
become a success or another great
question these days is how did you
overcome failure and the funny thing is
I found myself really kind of at a loss
because the very concepts of success and
failure I think are words that never
really meant anything and I actually I
strongly suspect they have a lot to do
with privilege that if you can make
yourself in the model of a research
professor of a hundred years ago that's
defined as a success and if you do
something difference defined as a
failure there's never been any time in
my life where you know even after having
received an award or having you know
been on a television show I sat back and
said boy I really feel like a success it
was always wrapped up in feelings of I
should have done something differently I
should have you know had a different
career path there's there's never been a
time where I felt like a success and at
the same time the idea that you ever
really fail at something there are
plenty of times that I very nearly
failed differential equations and
calculus you know there were things that
I was not very good at but I eventually
got them on say that the third or fourth
try
and the problem was just you know
staying around and telling yourself that
I really want to learn this I'm just not
gonna leave until I do
there wasn't any really true failure
either it was always kind of twisted up
with things I was proud of that I was
actually working through and trying to
learn so this idea that's at some point
in your life you're going to stop and
feel like a success yes I am successful
now I get very very nervous when people
ask me about that but how did you become
a success I want to sit them down and
tell them all the things I screwed up
and all the things I did wrong and all
the reasons I'm not a success and at the
same time when everybody anybody calls
me a failure it's like I want to sit you
down and explain why what I'm doing is
actually getting your money and your
funding for the rest of science you know
I'm not a failure either everything in
life is gonna be a flow between those
two things everything is going to be a
jumble of success and failure your
personal life your professional life the
way you feel about yourself and it's a
strange model we give young people try
to be a success try to overcome failure
I all I can do is just kind of breathe
and just realize that at no point in my
life am I going to separate those two
[Music]